-Our next guest is an Emmy-
and Tony-nominated actress
you know from shows
such as "Rectify,"
"Search Party," and her role
as Gerri on "Succession."
She's in the cast of the new
stop-motion comedy series
"In the Know," which begins
streaming on Peacock
January 25th.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, a woman my age doesn't
have to worry about style.
I always tell my hairdresser,
"Just try to make
my head look invisible."
-I think you look great.
Oh.
-Me too.
I'd totally smash.
For real, Barb.
-[ Stutters ]
Uh...thank -- thank you.
-You too, Carl.
-Hey!
-Please welcome to the show
J. Smith-Cameron, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, J. How are you?
-Hello. I'm well, thank you.
How are you?
-Good. I'm wonderful,
because I'm seeing you again,
after I saw you last week
at the Emmys.
You were nominated again.
Well-deserved.
-Lost again.
Lost again, but an honor
to be nominated, yes?
-Definitely.
It's an end in itself.
-And it was a good group.
You have to -- You were in a
very good category, good group.
-Yes. I mean, all those ladies
had really juicy parts,
and sometimes, I would just be
in like one scene an episode.
So, really, I had
no business even being...
-You had plenty of business
being there.
I thought it was a real
testament to your work that --
-I thought if I, by some chance,
won, I'd be like --
get up there and go,
"I demand a recount."
-You would demand a recount
against your own best interest.
-Yeah.
-It must be so special
when "Succession" wins,
especially this being
its last Emmys.
It must feel so great to even be
a part of a show that wins,
even though --
-Oh, definitely, definitely.
It was such
a collaborative show, too.
So that's particularly
true in those cases.
-I think one of the favorite
arcs of the show was, you know,
what happened
with Gerry and Roman.
I mean, it was
really cool, really weird.
And, certainly,
based on the first
few times
we saw you guys together,
none of us would have
predicted where it went.
I'm assuming the same for you.
-Yes, exactly. Exactly.
Yeah, it was a deeply strange.
-Deeply strange.
Making it even deeply --
more deeply strange,
you've known
Kieran Culkin forever.
He'd been in plays with you.
He'd been in films with you.
Your husband, Ken Lonergan,
a great playwright,
has worked with him many times.
Did that make it worse?
-[ Laughs ]
No, it made it easier.
Like, we were pals,
and I was used
to his snarky sense of humor.
And my husband has
a sarcastic sense of humor,
and I'm trying to learn
how to have
a more sarcastic sense of humor
and keep up with him.
No, I think it came about
because we would sort of mock
flirt on the set all the time.
And that show, the writers
were so collaborative with us,
they would take hints
from how we behaved on set
and then write toward that.
-Oh, my God.
So it's your fault.
[ Laughter ]
-It's Kieran's fault.
Kieran, by the way --
I love Kieran a great deal.
Kieran is an agent of chaos
in real life.
-Yes.
-And we actually have
a clip to prove
just what a little --
Like, he makes mischief.
And let's take a look at here
you are on the red carpet.
-Mom scams.
-And I love Kieran Culkin,
and he's my absolute
favorite to work with, even
though he's an ass[bleep] to me
and I hate him
in our personal life.
You really hate me, don't you?
-Yeah. Ooh!
-You look lovely.
You smell nice.
-Want to kiss?
-Okay.
-I mean, I get...
I get if the writers
of "Succession" saw that,
they're like, "We gotta --
We're missing something here."
Here's a photo you brought us.
Can you tell us what
happened to Kieran right there?
-Yes. So, that was one
evening after a table read.
And we all went to dinner,
and he was just riding me
the whole time, like,
being horrid.
And, like, if I couldn't
hear something that was --
Everyone would laugh
at something that was said
on the other end of the table.
And I'd be like,
"What'd he say? What'd he say?"
He'd be like,
"Oh, I'm sorry, dear.
Did you forget
your hearing aids?
Or, like, if I yawned,
he'd be like,
"Is it past your bedtime?
That's so terrible."
So, you know, at one point,
I just threw my martini at him.
-Yeah. There you go.
That's why you should --
Well, within your rights.
-Thank you.
-Well within your rights.
-He was asking for it.
-You are, you know,
a very integral cast member
on one of the biggest shows
in recent years.
I would imagine you get
recognized a great deal more.
I mean, you've been
onstage for years.
You've been in television
for years.
But it must be
a weird sensation.
Have you noticed the shift?
-Yes. Yes. Somewhat, yes.
-Yeah.
-Sometimes, people are like,
"Oh, Team Gerri," you know.
I don't really know if my name,
J. Smith-Cameron,
is known like --
-Gotcha. Right.
You're just Gerri to them.
Yes, okay.
-Like, I met the maître d' at a
popular restaurant recently,
and they said, "You know,
if you want to come in,
just text me,
and I'll put a word in.
You know,
I'll contact the maître d',
the person on the desk."
-And I tried that.
-Yeah.
-And I got there
before his text had come in,
and I was like, "Hi.
I'm J. Smith-Cameron."
And they were like, "Uh-huh.
Do you have a reservation?"
I was like, "No, no,
but, you know,
Courtney said he would call."
You know, nothing.
And it reminded me
of this old joke.
I don't know if you've ever
heard it, but, you know, okay,
the joke goes
a quasi-famous actress --
let's say her name
is J. Smith-Cameron --
is in a restaurant,
and, you know, the waiter brings
her the wrong dish or something
and is kind of snooty about it.
So J. Smith-Cameron goes,
"Do you know who I am?"
And the waiter says,
"Give me a hint."
And then the actress says,
"I'm J. Smith-Cameron."
And the waiter says,
"Give me another hint."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, before you had
this recognizable face and name,
you used to sneak into
the Plaza Hotel.
This was back in your --
before auditions.
You were living in
Washington Heights at the time.
-That's right.
-How would you find your way
to sneaking into the Plaza?
-Okay, yes, well, so,
I lived in Washington Heights,
which is, you know,
very far from Midtown,
where all the auditions
seemed to be.
And I just developed a sort of
Holly Golightly kind of routine
where I found that the restrooms
at the Plaza Hotel,
which was then still a hotel --
they had a wonderful woman
working there,
and there would be, like,
cosmetics laid out.
And you could wash your face.
You could brush your teeth.
And, you know, I'd tip her and
I'd have a little chat with her.
And then I would go to
Bergdorf Goodman
and put on makeup.
And then I was kind of
camera-ready for my --
-Oh, very well-played.
-Yeah.
-Very well played.
And I knew which
hotel lobbies were friendly.
You could go in and look
at your sides.
-Oh! Well, there. Look at that.
-Yeah.
-You have a daughter,
21 years old,
and I'm wondering --
who's also, I should note,
has known, then,
Kieran her whole life.
That's exactly right.
-Does that make
"Succession" hard to watch?
-She refuses to watch it.
When she heard about that
relationship, she was like,
"Mom --" Like, she got home
from school that day.
She was like, "Mom,
is what I heard true?"
And I was like,
"Well, I think so."
And she went like,
"How could you?
Why would you do that?"
And I was like, "Well, you know,
I didn't single-handedly do it.
You know, it's written
into the story."
But she was like --
-And one would say
Kieran single-handedly did it.
-Yes, yes. I know. By the way.
And, so -- But she was,
you know, she's not --
she's a really sweet kid.
Like, she's a good kid,
but she's a really fun,
witty sense of humor.
But, you know, when they're
teenagers or middle-school age,
they get so embarrassed
all the time.
Like, I remember trying to wake
her up for middle school
and I'm trying to wake myself up
to walk into middle school,
and I was blasting
Michael Jackson
and singing along with it.
And she was just like,
"Mom, cut that out.
You're so embarrassing."
And I was like, "Nellie,
we're alone in the apartment."
And she said, "Mom, that's how
embarrassing you are."
-I had a sweeter version
of the same thing.
My son and I were dancing
the other day,
and he goes, "I love
when you dance at home."
And he goes, "But I don't think
you should do it
out of the house."
That was a very funny clip
of this beautiful animation,
gorgeous animation.
-They're puppets.
-And you play a producer
on an NPR-style show.
Exactly, exactly.
-And did you enjoy --
That must have been nice to --
I mean, considering
all the travel
and the locations
of "Succession,"
it must have been nice
just to go into a sound booth.
-Yes, it was. It was great.
It was a really good group.
Also very collaborative
kind of team.
-Yeah.
-My character is sort of
the straight man, in a way,
although she says funny things.
She's the producer
of the NPR show
and sort of the
den mother of them.
-Well, it's very funny.
I highly recommend it.
And it's just been
so lovely having you here, J.
Thanks for coming.
Come again soon.
J. Smith-Cameron, everybody.
"In the Know"
begins streaming on Peacock
January 25th.
It's very funny.
We'll be right back with music
from Baby Tate.